F
THAT REPUBLICANS LIKE THAT THEY
STILL WON'T SUPPORT BECAUSE
THEY JUST DON'T WANT TO GET THE
OTHER SIDE OF VICTORY.
AND BOTH SIDES DO THAT KIND OF
STUFF.
BUT TONIGHT, I JUST WANT TO SAY,
IF YOU WERE BITING YOUR
FINGERNAILS, WORRIED ABOUT THE
WORLD, WORRIED ABOUT AMERICA,
AND YOU WATCH THIS PRESIDENT
TONIGHT, THIS IS A PRESIDENT
THAT IS FINDING COMMON GROUND.
AND SPEAKING COMMON SENSE.
AND TRYING TO TURN COMMON PAIN
INTO COMMON PURPOSE.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU NEED RIGHT
NOW.
>> DAVID, YOU WORK IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
SO MAYBE YOU CAN GIVE ME A
LITTLE APPRECIATION TO THIS.
A LOT OF US, INCLUDING A LOT OF
YOU AS U.S. OFFICIALS WERE
EMBRACING TUA HEAVY RUSSIAN
ASSAULT DURING THE COURSE OF
THE PRESIDENTS ADDRESS.
THE STATE OF THE UNION ADDRESS.
THEY THOUGHT THERE WOULD BE
EXPLOSIONS AND SIRENS GOING OFF
AND BOMBS WHILE THE PRESIDENT
WAS SPEAKING.
IT WAS TOTALLY QUIET.
BY OUR REPORTERS ACCOUNTS OVER
THERE.
WHICH, I AM SURE SAID SOMETHING
ABOUT THE RUSSIAN INTENTION
RIGHT.
NOW WHY WERE THEY EFFECTIVELY,
SORT OF RESPECTFUL.
HERE'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
DOING --
>> I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT.
WHAT I DO KNOW IS THAT BIDEN'S
TEAM PROBABLY NO MORE THAN WE
DO ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE I'M SURE HE WAS BEING
BRIEFED RIGHT UP TO GOING.
IT AND I'M SURE THAT THEY
WEREN'T THRILLED ABOUT THE IDEA
ABOUT A SPLIT SCREEN SITUATION
WHERE THEY WERE DELIVERING THE
STATE OF THE UNION.
WHERE A MASSACRE WAS TAKING
PLACE IN UKRAINE.
I SUSPECT THEY KNEW WHEN HE GOT
ON THAT PLATFORM WHAT'S THE
SITUATION WAS.
LET ME JUST SAY ONE THING.
YOU SAID YOU WORKED IN THAT
WHITE HOUSE.
I JUST FEEL LIKE AFTER SAY,
THAT SOMETIME DURING THIS
DISCUSSION, THE THING I HATED
THE MOST WHEN I WORKED IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WAS WORKING DAY AND
NIGHT ON A SPEECH.
AND EVERYTHING ELSE YOU'RE
WORKING ON AND THEN HAVING AN X
IN THE WHITE HOUSE LIKE ME,
HERE'S WHAT THEY SHOULD'VE
DONE.
[LAUGHS]
I THINK THAT THERE WAS A LOT
THAT WAS ACCOMPLISHED TONIGHT.
I JUST THINK THAT THERE IS AN
URGE TO ACCOMPLISH TOO MUCH.
AND THAT CAN SOMETIMES REDUCE
THE IMPACT OF WHAT YOU MEAN TO
DO.
>> LET'S JUST WAIT TO SEE WHAT
THE RUSSIANS ARE UP TO IN THE
COMING OUT ORDERS.
AND JAKE, BACK TO YOU.
>> THANK, YOU ARE GETTING THE
FIRST RESULTS OF THE POLLS OF
AMERICANS WHO WATCHED PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S SPEECH TONIGHT.
DAVID IS HERE WITH THE NUMBERS.
DAVID?
>> JAKE, WE SHOULD FIRST KNOW
THIS IS NOT A POLL OBVIOUSLY OF
ALL AMERICANS.
THAT WOULD NOT BE POSSIBLE
HERE.
THIS IS A POLL OF PEOPLE WHO
WATCH THE SPEECH.
AND WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE
ABOUT THAT IS PEOPLE WHO WATCH
THE PRESIDENT GIVING HIS STATE
OF THE UNION TEND TO BE MORE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PRESIDENT OR
IN THAT PRESIDENTS PARTY.
WE SEE THIS WITH DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTS AND REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS.
SO, OUR SURVEY TONIGHT OF
SPEECH WATCHERS IS ABOUT 11
POINT MORE DEMOCRATIC THAN AS A
BODY OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD HOPE
IN THE OVERALL POPULATION IN
AMERICA.
SO, JUST KEEP THAT IN MIND AS
WE NOW SHOW YOU WHAT'S THIS
INSTANT REACTION WAS FOR THE
UPHOLD OF SPEECH WATCHERS WAS
TONIGHT.
41% HAD A VERY POSITIVE
REACTION.
29%, SOMEWHAT POSITIVE.
29%, NEGATIVE.
THAT 41%, WHEN YOU COMPARED TO
LATCH'S YOUR SPEECH THAT JOE
BIDEN GAVE TO A CONGRESS,
THAT'S ABOUT TEN POINTS LAWYER
ON THE VERY POSITIVE SCALE.
51% LAST YEAR, YOU SEE 41%
TODAY.
IN FACT, THAT 41% IS THE LOWEST
VERY POSITIVE WE'VE SEEN IN
ABOUT 15 YEARS OF INSTANT
POLLING AFTER THE STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS QUESTION
HERE, WE SAID, DID BIDEN DO
ENOUGH TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MAJOR ISSUES?
HERE ON RUSSIA'S INVASION OF
UKRAINE, 69% SAID, THE
PRESIDENT DID ENOUGH TO ADJUST
THAT.
BUT, LOOK AT THIS.
THE DOMESTIC ISSUES THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE IS SO KEENLY AWARE
OF IN THIS MIDTERM ELECTION
YEAR THAT ARE POTENTIAL PROBLEM
SURVIVE AND, THEY STILL SEEM TO
BE PROBLEMS.
47% SAID HE DID ENOUGH ON
INFLATION.
46% SAID HE DID ENOUGH ON
VIOLENT CRIME.
MAJORITIES FOR BOTH INFLATION
AND VIOLENT CRIME SAID HE DID
NOT DO ENOUGH.
AND AGAIN, I JUST WANT TO
REMIND YOU, THAT IS THE
MAJORITY OF A SPEECH WATCHING
AUDIENCE THAT IS MORE
DEMOCRATIC THAN THE AMERICAN
POPULATION OVERALL.
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS YOU LOOK
AT THAT.
HOW ABOUT CHANGING YOUR LEVEL
OF CONFIDENCE IN THE WAY BIDEN
IS HANDLING THE SITUATION IN
UKRAINE?
AFTER THE SPEECH TONIGHT, THE
SWATCHES SAID, 30% OF THEM ARE
MORE CONFIDENT IN HIS ABILITY
AND THE ABILITY TO HANDLE THE
SITUATION IN UKRAINE.
ONLY 14% LESS CONFIDENT.
BUT 50% HAD NO CHANGE IN MIND
ABOUT HOW JOE BIDEN'S HANDLING
THE UKRAINE SITUATION.
AND THEN YOU WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT WHICH SPEECH TOPIC IS
MORE FOR VIEW.
THE ECONOMY OR UKRAINE?
THIS EXPLAINS WHY TEN MINUTES,
12 MINUTES OF A 62-MINUTE
SPEECH WAS DEDICATED TO
UKRAINE.
AND THE OTHER 15 MINUTES WERE
DEDICATED TO OTHER THINGS.
BECAUSE 64% OF SPEECH WATCHERS
SAY THE ECONOMY IS MORE
IMPORTANT.
36% SAY UKRAINE WAS THE MORE
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
>> SO GENERALLY SPEAKING, THESE
ARE LOWER MARKS THAN YOU WOULD
EXPECT FROM SUCH A
DISPROPORTIONATELY DEMOCRATIC
AUDIENCE?
>> WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST
YEAR JOE BIDEN TAKE A SLIDE IN
THE POLLS.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
HE IS NOT JUST TAKING A SLIDE
WITH THE OVERALL PUBLIC.
HE'S ALSO TAKING A SLIDE, AND I
THINK THIS REFLECTS THAT, THE
INSTANT REACTION SPEECH, WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE EVEN SUPPORTIVE
OF HIM.
OR IN HIS PARTY.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, THAT IS
WHAT THESE NUMBERS REFLECT.
HE, OBVIOUSLY, HAS BEEN ON THE
DECLINE.
THERE IS NOTHING IN THE SPEECH
THAT SUGGESTS HE TURNED THAT
AROUND.
ENTIRELY, I DON'T THINK THAT'S
THE EXPECTATION.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S A
REALISTIC EXPECTATION FOR THE
SPEECH.
BUT CLEARLY, THAT DECLINE IN
POPULARITY THAT WE HAVE SEEN,
WE ARE SEEING IT ACROSS THE
BOARD.
>> AND WHAT'S INTERESTING ABOUT
THAT IS I THINK, I'M NOT
TELLING TALES OUT OF SCHOOL,
THAT HIS NUMBERS WHEN IT COMES
TO INFLATION AND VIOLENT CRIME
ARE MUCH MORE IMPORTANT AS TO
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS THIS NOVEMBER.
AND ALSO WHAT HAPPENS TO HIS
REELECTION SHOULD HE RUN FAIRLY
--
REELECTION IN 2024.
MOST PEOPLE ARE NOT GOING TO BE
VOTING FOR THE PRESIDENT ON
FOREIGN POLICY.
>> INFLATION AND THE BROADER
ISSUES OF THE ECONOMY OF HOW
PEOPLE FEEL ABOUT THEIR
POCKETBOOKS, AND HOW PEOPLE
FEEL ABOUT THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS,
WORRYING ABOUT CRIME, THAT'S
THE POLITICAL BALL GAME.
THAT IS WHAT EVERY MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, DEMOCRATIC AND
REPUBLICAN MEMBER OF CONGRESS
WILL TELL YOU THAT THEY BELIEVE
THE VOTERS ARE GOING TO BE
CARRYING THE MOST ABOUT WHEN
THEY DECIDE WHETHER REPUBLICANS
SHOULD TAKE THE MAJORITY IN THE
HOUSE AND IN THE SENATE.
AND THEY KNOW THAT ON CAPITOL
HILL.
THEY VERY MUCH KNOW THAT AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
WHICH IS WHY YOU SAID, AS YOU
SAID DAVID, AS MUCH AS
UNDERSTANDABLY --
IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THAT
EVERYBODY'S FOCUSED ON UKRAINE.
AND THAT THE PRESIDENT STARTED
THERE.
AND AT THE BULK OF HIS SPEECH
WAS ABOUT THAT.
BUT JUST ONE QUICK THING ON
THAT.
THE CRIME, THAT NUMBER.
THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT DID
NOT JUST DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM
DEFUND THE POLICE.
WHICH HE DID THROUGHOUT THE
WHOLE TIME.
HE NEVER EMBRACE THAT.
IN FACT, HE WAS VERY MUCH
SAYING HE WAS VERY SUPPORTIVE.
BUT THEN HE USE THE TERM, FUND
THE POLICE.
HE TURNED IT ON HIS HEAD.
THAT TELLS YOU EVERYTHING YOU
NEED TO KNOW ABOUT WHERE THE
DEMOCRATS THINK THEY ARE IN
THIS ISSUE.
>> ALTHOUGH, I HAVE TO SAY
YOU'RE MAKING THIS OBSERVATION
EARLIER.
IT IS AMAZING TO ME, GOVERNOR
REYNOLDS, TALKING ABOUT PARENTS
RIGHTS.
TALKING ABOUT EDUCATION.
SEEING THROUGH THAT LENS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DID TALK ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF SCHOOLS, THEM
STAYING OPEN IN THE CONTEXT OF
COVID.
HE DID TALK ABOUT INCREASING
FUNDING.
BUT DEMOCRATS SEEM TO HAVE
CONSISTENTLY SEE THIS IDEA THAT
PARENTS RIGHTS AND PARENTS
INVOLVEMENT IN SCHOOLS TO
REPUBLICANS.
REPUBLICANS ARE TAKING UP THE
MANTLE OF THIS OF PARENTS
RIGHTS.
PARENTS GET TO HAVE A SAY.
DEMOCRATS SEEM TO JUST NOT SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
AND WE SAW HOW WELL THAT WORKED
UP FOR THE DEMOCRATS WHEN THE
REPUBLICAN CONTROL OF THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION IN VIRGINIA.
>> THEY ARE TALKING TO VOTERS
ABOUT TWO COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SETS OF ISSUES.
THAT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN MORE
PRONE.
TONIGHT YOU'RE RIGHT.
DEMOCRATS BY AND LARGE JUST
IGNORED.
THEY DON'T RESPOND TO IT.
THEY DON'T PUSH BACK ON.
IT THEY JUST IGNORE THE
ARGUMENTS BEING MADE ON
SO-CALLED PARENTS RIGHTS.
BECAUSE, WHAT'S MORE PUBLICANS
ARE CALLING PRINCE RIGHT SEEM
TO ONLY REFERRED TO CERTAIN
KINDS OF PARENTS.
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE PARENTS
WHO DO WANT THEIR KIDS TO WEAR
MASKS OR TO LEARN ABOUT RACE IN
SCHOOLS, ETC.
BUT DEMOCRATS ARE TALKING ABOUT
THOSE ISSUES.